I don't like either of these guys I
think well yeah magicians come on the
worst kr let's rank them what are they
the work are they worse than anybody
else in show business or what's worse
morning DJ's are worse morning DJ's
vengeance
where did Minds fit into that minds are
in show business
minds are buskers I like that well I
gotta have a little illness to help me
decide out this one I know what what I'm
thinking well I don't know what I'm
thinking so help me out all right there
were some critical moments in this case
first of all Dorian he admitted that he
said the word borrowed he said borrowed
I borrowed that yes he said it on
the other hand rod said that he stole it
from the other dude but then he said
it's okay because as soon as it's
published then you can just do it but it
was published and Dorian can just do it
exactly ho television 1,000 bucks is
seems like a lot to me to act asked to
say yeah I want $5,000 because he took
my trick also I looked at these new
autumn $5,000 sketch right there no the
drawings do not fully represent what I
saw Dorian doing the drawings have none
of Dorian's flair the other thing was uh
I remember what the other thing was wait
I'm the one that's smoking
[Music]